ja und dieses eingreifen der polizei das
können wir jetzt in diesen minuten auch
beobachten unter den linden vor der
russischen botschaft dort kam ist heute
mehrfach zu ausschreitungen es flogen
flaschen auf die 3000 beamten die heute
im einsatz sind und wir wollen uns jetzt
einmal live vor ort anschauen wie jetzt
dort die stimmung ist mein kollege
fabian matzerath ist vor ort es gab
immer wieder festnahmen und es wurden
auch demonstranten festgesetzt
weggetragen fabian wie ist es jetzt in
zahlreiche polizisten dort und
zahlreichen gesprächen
[Applaus]
er hat gesprochen und festgenommen
foto cremer von und ist jetzt von der
polizei gerade festgenommen worden
er hat fünf minuten wieder gehetzt und
wird jetzt von der polizei abgeführt
[Applaus]
das ist jetzt die berühmteste festnahme
würde ich mal so sagen er hat liga 56 78
minuten lang im griff und ist von der
polizei festgenommen worden
ausnahme ist natürlich wäre es gerade ja
fabian vielen herzlichen dank für deine
einschätzungen gesehen werde ich radio
live bilder vor der russischen botschaft
dort wurde attila hildmann festgenommen
tv-koch aber eben auch große stimme der
verschwörungstheoretiker der korona
leugner werden jetzt gerade
live bilder gesehen wie er von der
polizei festgesetzt wurde vorher hielt
er am weißes gebäude eine rede und wie
schaut seine kruden theorien muss man
sagen über verschwörungstheorien und
über corona abwehr wurde jetzt
festgesetzt sind hier gerade die live
bilder unseres reporters fabian
matzerath vor ort